[Music]
the goal of this workshop
is to have community prepared to respond
to opioid overdoses we need to be able
to address this issue
from the ground up south central was
started
out of the need for hiv education in
southern west virginia and
it was actually developed as a
organization that
targeted african americans and as we got
out and we were doing the work in rural
communities
it was very evident that everyone needed
it
so we moved from a minority based
program to a general population program
we are funded through the national
library of medicine
they have been supporting our technology
programs here in
the building and their mission is
presenting high quality wellness
information that is trusted easy to
understand and free
we first became connected with sced
in 2012 their first application from us
was based on community outreach to
reduce health disparities and stigmas
then we realized that there was a need
for technology because
having a computer lab available for
people at a community center where they
can look up
health information in general was really
important
project towards is technology outreach
to reduce health disparities
being able to access the national
library of medicine's database gives us
tools
to help teach people how they can go and
find information
you know there's not a lot of
opportunities here this is an area that
really lacks in resources
south central education development
is the only one around here having any
[Music]
impact
you